you guys I'm so excited I have all of
the brand new white accessories from
Road there is so much fun gear here and
I cannot wait to check it out we've got
the new white pod mic the new smaller
roadter duo in white this I'm so excited
about because I have the fulls sizee
version right now on my desk and I don't
have a lot of room plus this new white
aesthetic is going to look so good in my
office we've also got the nth 100
professional over the ear headphones
also in white oh look at this this is
the professional studio arm in white but
what's interesting though is I've got
this an XLR cable it is not white all
right first things
first wow oh this looks so freaking
[Music]
good this is beautiful I love how it
looks and this white So Fresh So this
has two XLR inputs and the larger
version has four so honestly for me at
my desk I don't even need more than one
so this is going to be perfect for that
next up we've got the white pod
mic oo here it
is oh yeah this looks
amazing next up the
headphones oh look at these These are so
awesome love I love how light they are
these are going to be great for when me
and my sister finally decide to record
our podcast again all right now here is
the studio
arm this is going to look so good with
the new white pod mic on it all right
well I'm pretty happy with how this all
look so far now it's time to get it all
set up so here's the before setup I've
got kind of like a little pink theme
going on I've got my pink keyboard my
mouse my microphone and even my
headphones so now it's time to switch it
up the one thing that I actually don't
have though is a white keyboard or
Mouse I couldn't continue setting up
that desk because I needed to have white
accessories so I hopped over to Best Buy
this is the Viper V2 Pro and this is the
death stalker V2 Pro keyboard oo so
fresh oh this is nice super low
profile not too loud either I like
it oh look at you looks so
good okay love the white cabling
Perfect Just What We
Needed nice time to finish the
[Music]
setup
okay everything is all set up the one
thing you're going to notice is the arm
for the microphone is not on the desk
because the desk that I have here it's
too thick like I can't actually find any
Mount that will actually mount on here
so I don't know if I need to like make
something drill some holes I don't know
for now though this mic stand seems to
be doing the trick this is what I was
using before and it'll do I love all of
these white accessories like obviously
pink is my aesthetic but these look so
good together that I can't wait to sit
here work and game and maybe even do
some streams let me know what you guys
think of the new white setup I love
[Music]
it